[Music]
well you will see that we are slowly
moving through MIT we've had the
theoretical construct for the
relationship between art and science
from the school of science now we've had
our presentation from the School of
Architecture and we are moving on to the
School of Engineering there is probably
no better representative from the School
of Engineering and representing men's at
Manos mind and hand then Richard Pollock
class of 1965 who is president of the
talax foundry for art's casting at the
talax foundry sculptures monumental
sculptures by many of the best-known
artists have been casted are being
casted works by de Kooning stella nancy
graves joel shapiro and many many others
i think to describe what dick does there
i've been privileged to be to talax
twice and i would really like to take
all of you to talax to see the foundry
but we will have to come and show us
pictures of it it's maybe next time we
should go to the Louvre and go to the
foundry ins
but there was a profile about dick in
the current technology review which I
hope that you were able to see and I
want to quote one passage from that it
says dick is multilingual he speaks
structural engineer sculptor and welder
fluently please help me to welcome dick
polish
[Applause]
well good morning I we all need a little
second to let all that settle down that
was just a wonderful talk and and what
I'm going to talk about is a little bit
different I am an engineer a
metallurgist thirty years ago I worked
on a project with Mert Fleming's head of
the material science department the goal
of which modestly stated was to unite
technology and art we did indeed have a
resident sculptor we al dukkha who still
is here in Boston we all work together
to adapt and modify industrial
techniques to the making of art 24 years
ago I started talax a place to make art
whose very name comes from the material
we deal with metallics in that 24 years
talax has grown to be the largest caster
fabricator in the world with over a
hundred people working in 85,000 square
feet making art for artists all over the
world in fact in the past year we've
installed art in Luxembourg Munster
Germany Rome Vancouver and Tokyo my hope
today is accomplished three things first
to give you a tour of the foundry and
show you what we do secondly to talk
about a specific problem for artists
going from a small maquette to a
monument the the problem of dealing with
scale and then finally end up with a
discussion of how artists engineers and
fabricators work together so let's let's
begin the artist who wants to make metal
sculpture needs to find at least four
things space tools technology and craft
the artist will always make art but
where he makes that art the place he
picks will affect how the art looks and
how it is made let's look at the first
slide there pointer here
this is it okay space we have we have
plenty of we have about 85,000 square
feet we have 46 foot ceilings the the
next slide you see now I'm not sure
where that is oh there we go
thank you the next slide shows the main
Bay of tallix we have some frank stella
stuff over here there's a Lichtenstein
over there
that's audrey flack that's a stainless
steel sculpture by jeff koons
the scale of the place it's about 65
feet across here and about 300 feet down
to the other end of the foundry the
cranes have about 35 foot clear under
the hook and and can lift up to a
hundred thousand pounds tools also we
have plenty of the next slide here you
see us out in the yard assembling a
sculpture by Alex Lieberman it's it's a
core 10 steel sculpture it's dimensions
are 50 by 50 by 40 feet it's it's an
extraordinary sculpture in that you can
walk inside this sculpture and and it's
it's very unusual in that way the the
next slide we show some technology this
is a sculpture that's in the National
Gallery a quite famous sculpture and
it's its surface is terrible and and
this is this is one of the things that
we have worked on at Alex to to help
sculptors achieve their goals the next
slide these are the grain sizes of three
different cast bronze alloys and and
while I was at MIT I did work on bearing
steels and and it turns out that the the
same kinds of things that make better
bearing Steel's also make better
surfaces for sculptors and
so in the next slide you you see some
some of the stuff we have done where the
where the cosmetic appearance of the
surface the the perfection is so vital
to what the artist is is trying to get
across in the next slide you see craft I
mean this this kind of story is really
the story of tallix we where we have
analyzed and identified those
interactions between artists and and
craftsmen where they are really working
together to make art we we have also got
processes steps in the process that that
really are very little different than
making an engine block and so we have
tried to separate those processes
mechanize them use the latest techniques
and and try to keep this marriage of
technology and and craft going along in
in the next slide you see a triptych by
Helen Frankenthaler and these really are
lithographs set in in a cast stainless
steel frame these are about 7 feet high
one of the problems in in this in this
sculpture was what to do with the
backsides and and we tried putting
fabric and putting wood and and and and
various other kinds of things and and
then the next slide please
we we went to using patinas and patinas
are are very painterly kinds of things
and you use brushes and solutions the
solutions are chemical but but the
techniques are the same in the next
slide you see Helen working on the the
bronze backs that that went on onto the
triptychs and
the the this process is very much like
using watercolors the the the colors are
transparent they blend into each other
and and there there's ample opportunity
for for accidents happy accidents to
occur in in the next slide you see one
of the one of the triptychs and and this
is now is the backside and you can see
the incredible designs and colors that
that she has done for the back of the
screens in the next slide is another one
and and and then in the next slide again
and another design and colors and and I
must say that at the exhibit where these
were were shown the only one of the
triptychs had the lithographs facing out
and then the lithographs were all facing
the wall as they showed all the backs
and so there was some happy foundry men
at that show in the in the next in the
next slide this again is is is is a
little bit of of Technology and a lot of
craft one of the things that that is
going on here is that we are we are
brush plating gold onto the bronze what
happens then is that that the patinas
will not take on the gold and so that
the artist gets this kind of
extraordinary transition from from here
a green into this into the rich Goldy
color I think the next slide shows it oh
no this this is a another case of craft
coming through to help the artist the
the the woman there is Mary Frank who
does clay sculpture one of the things
that that that really troubled Mary was
the she wanted to do marble and of
course fired clay is very fragile
and and the the possibilities for
putting it outdoors are limited she
wanted to do metal sculpture but but the
surfaces were were hard and and just
reflective and really bothered her and
so we worked out this this approach
where we got a kind of matte surface
with a patina that came close to the
original clays in the next slide I'm
going to to now talk about about some of
the problems with with scale these are
35 foot figures in Rosslyn outside of
Washington DC it's what you see as you
come up to this building the thing that
goes on when when an artist is faced
with with with with making a large-scale
monument and and as professor Morrison
talked about the hands and the eye
working together artists invariably work
at a size somewhere between a foot and
three feet something like that I think
the hands and the eyes coordinate well
and and that's the size now you you
you've got to make something though that
can be outdoors something to go in the
world and the world is a big place well
typically if I took a piece of paper and
crushed it in my hand and threw it on
the table you would you would sense the
force that had had had crushed it you
would see the folds the lines the kind
of energy that's in that piece of paper
in that crumpled paper I now take it and
and and an artist says well make it 10
feet by 10 feet what happens is that
somehow now all of those folds and
creases and lines have moved apart and
and there's there's a there's a lot of
information that has to be put back in
to make that work and and what is
possible to have happened is that this
this large model it is it becomes an
imitation thing
and it really doesn't work in this case
the the next slide please we were taking
as a starting point of painting and
we're working with kind of big geometric
simple shapes the next slide we we have
here again in the Bay of the foundry and
and we are are making this structure
we've got the problem of hurricane winds
you'll see that it's quite delicately
poised on it on its toes so we have to
put a lot of structure inside this the
next slide please
here we are in the main bay of the
foundry the figures standing together
for the first time you can see all of
these are really well points where that
where the surface skin is welded to the
structure inside and there indeed is a
copy of the original painting and and
that is the artist admiring her work the
next slide
this is what you see as you leave the
building and I think this is just a very
successful project it's it's a it's a
wonderful kind of thing to see coming
and going in the next slide we have a
sculpture by Roy Lichtenstein and this
is a brush stroke
the next slide shows this sculpture at I
think it's 22 feet in the foundry and
then the next slide shows it going into
a building in Paris of all places but
but again you can see that there are big
simple forms the colors are well-defined
and and this sculpture goes up to a
larger scale quite readily the next
slide this is a two-dimensional painting
by an artist named Richard Pugh set dart
and I was really quite amazed to see in
one of mr. pace slides which showed a
topographic map of Paris how this
related to that it seems close to
one of the things I don't know if that
was mr. darts mr. Pooh said darts
inspiration but one of the things that
that we had to do now in consultation
with the artist was to figure out what's
up and what's down how do we make this
three-dimensional and so we made it into
a clay model next slide please
and you can see now this this is the
modeling clay it's gone from a painting
about I think it was five feet by six
feet to it to a twelve by twelve drawer
this door was for the museum at the
Indianapolis Museum of Art and in in in
the next slide you see the door set in
in the limestone wall the next slide
shows the inside of the building and the
door is is pivoted in the middle and so
it rotates an essential hinge and I
think we have one more slide which shows
again that the door said in the building
again I think a very successful
enlargement the next slide this is a
sculpture by Tom Otterness which which
went to Germany
here is the maquette this is about three
feet high and we're enlarging it to
eight meters that the construction here
is quite simple stainless steel tubes
with with bronze elements inside them
the next slide please
here you see it in in the main Bay the
foundry at its full height I think that
that is the model there and again here
is the sculpture again this sculpture
lent itself readily to - to being
enlarged next slide here we are in
Washington and and what's going on here
is that this is the installation of the
Joel Shapiro sculpture at the Holocaust
Museum in Washington this sculpture was
was
23 feet high the next slide shows the
sculpture in the foundry shapiro uses
wooden forms the the sculptures are
almost minimum they're these simple
wouldn't wooden forms that they'd go
together this this is a figure that it's
it's a double figure that represents a
kind of resurrection theme you see here
the actual size of the elements that we
that we cast there was a real problem
here in that in that when the sculpture
got this big the the and we used wooden
beams to cast off of the wood grain did
not carry and Shapiro finally went back
to the sawmill and deemed one of the
teeth of the saw and then ran it through
the saw mill and and left the pattern
that was strong enough to to come
through at this scale that the next
slide shows Joel that's Joel the artist
they're now adjusting locating the
sculpture and and and this is just
interesting that it that it shows the
kind of involvement that goes on between
artist and fabricator engineer next
slide this this is a sculpture by
Gifford Proctor and and this sculpture
is about 30 inches high and it's it's
Washington at Valley Forge very very
dramatic it was on its way to 20 feet
and in the next slide you you see the
enlarging machine at the foundry this is
this is a pointing device the the
original sits on this table the the
thing you're making in clay works over
here they're two styli the
the centerline of the tables and the
centerline of this arm is on the same
point there's a pivot back there and so
that this makes one similar triangle
it's similar to this so if this distance
is one and this is five you can get a
five times magnification this technology
goes back to the Renaissance so it's
it's being displaced by by lasers and
devices like that but computers excuse
me
computer driven cutting machines at this
scale it's just very difficult the
equipment is so expensive
next slide here we have the body these
are washington's elbows and and and and
what what happens now is we really start
to get into trouble because we've got
we've got this enormous expanse of
fabric or cloth or whatever it is and
it's it's a real problem as to what to
do to keep the sculpture interesting to
keep your eye moving this sculpture was
was really never never cast at that
scale let's go on to the next slide
please
here we have an artist vilem de Kooning
and the Kooning did this sculpture which
is nine inches high and and then it was
a lard enlarged four times to three feet
and then four times to twelve feet and
in the next slide the the kind of
technique that the Kooning was using was
was really working these things in his
hand squeezing clay in his hand and and
you can see the in in in the next slide
you can see this kind of very tactile
thing that's missing that's going on and
and in the in the next slide again you
see it even better now these sculptures
when they were first enlarged the the
first enlargements were really scrapped
because the the the information from
there too there which was was was not
there and the artists had to come back
and and work very closely with with the
enlarger to get something that that kept
your eye moving that that kept your
interest the next slide please
this is this is frank stella and and
frank stella is certainly one of the one
of the one of the top artists of our
time and and and stella is here working
on a clay and he looks like he's working
with a rake well he is working with a
rake and and Stella's a really a
cerebral available guy who who will
discuss with you and and tell you what
his problems are in and he's got a clay
here the total clay is about 12 feet
across and and he's he's trying to make
a mark on it that's that's appropriate
to the scale and and Stella feels that
that the hands are too small too weak
the the gestures they make are too too
timid I mean what what he's looking for
is is is something that that will it was
show force and movement and energy and
and so I've actually seen him go in
there and jump on the clay with with
both feet I mean it's it's a real
problem and and in the next slide you
see how Stella is is is starting to
approach it the this this is part of a
sculpture which you'll see in a minute
it's it's about 25 feet high this this
one element and and in it we we have an
enormous number of new forms of new
surfaces of things that that that Frank
is trying to do
keep you interested to have a surface
that that's dynamic and changing and and
interesting in the in the next slide
here is here's another sculpture and I'm
going to talk a little bit more about
this but this this dumpster is actually
part of the sculpture and and I agreed
but but I I'm going to talk about that
about where an artist gets his images
and and and one of the one of the things
that Alex is is a resource image Bank
for artists and almost everything we we
use in the foundry Frank has put in one
sculpture or another but the next slide
this is this is another sculpture and
they're these these are also painterly
things I mean Stella started out as a
painter and a painter can take 12 inch
wide brush and go in and and and and cut
out big big parts of his painting by
over painting and and and Stella is
looking for that same kind of energy and
possibility for change the next slide
please
this is that sculpture it was it was
that one one reviewer described the
sculptures looking like an airplane
crash
and that's that's funny in a way but but
it's it's it's also it's it's also true
I mean Frank is is is looking for
gestures and and and you take a big
steel tank and you crush it and and and
so you you you put that the history of
that event in there and and and we
respond to it and sense it in the next
slide again some some of some of these
things that are going on and and then
closer in the next slide closer to my
heart here we are trying to make one of
these forms and and and Stella is so
experimental and so open that I'm going
to talk some more about him in a minute
but here we are he has assembled this
this pile of junk and sometimes I mean
there's no other word for it it really
is a lot of junk but we are pouring
5,000 pounds of aluminum on this
sculpture on this stuff to make a new
kind of form I mean this this is a kind
of casting without moles and and what
happens is we get we get directional
patterns the things get knit together
and and we have here a really a new mode
of expression and and again going back
to Professor Morrison's talk about the
real world this this is very real world
but it's also dreamland so I think
that's the last slide no I I have some
other slides and again going back to
professor Morrison talked and we did not
discuss each other's talk but here one
of the things that that really binds me
as an as an engineer to the casting
process is the process itself and in
early times people who worked
with metals were Shaymin they were they
were they were magicians they I mean
after all that the first metals meteors
from heaven and and mother earth
disgorging gold nuggets and so the
metals have always had a very powerful
role in our lives and this this this is
these are ceramic shells that we're
going to fill with metal and we preheat
them because they're so impermeable and
and we have to keep the metal molten
long enough to fill out the next slide
shows us pigging off not pinging off
tapping off into a crucible of molten
steel and then the next slide is the
actual casting process which is which is
violent and wonderful and dangerous next
slide again more of that and then and
then the last slide is the moles have
been poured and they're set aside the
cool and the next slide is just entropy
taking over and everything getting back
to the same temperature ok I think
that's it for the slides I want now to
talk a little bit after now we've seen
how the foundry looks I want to talk
about how it works but first it should
be understood that the art being
discussed is limited to the plastic arts
and sculpture in particular we'll begin
by making a clear distinction between
creating fabricating and engineering
creating well difficult to understand is
fairly easy to describe it's what the
artist does when he works when he
express himself what it is not is
something made as a means to an end
something made to a preconceived plan or
something made by imposing a new form on
a given material in other words art is
made deliberately and responsibly by
people who know what they're doing
even though they don't know and Vance
what is going to come of it to create a
work of art the artist must have a name
certain unexpressed feelings and the
wherewithal to express them making a
sculpture then has to
stages making the plan which is creating
and then imposing that plan on certain
materials which is fabricating thus when
the engineer makes a plan he likes the
artist is creating it is not art however
because it has a preconceived goal
remember in art you don't have a
preconceived problem to solve you're
trying to express something sometimes
the engineer is in my case whereas two
hats he makes the plan but then he also
serves as the fabricator let's look at
fabricating the fabricator needs an idea
of what is to be made
typically the artist presents an
artifact in a plastic medium and once it
transformed into metal perhaps at a
larger scale in the simplest case the
engineer is not needed at all the deal
is really between artist and fabricator
in this case the artist has a very
specific problem which can be solved by
the application of an existing
technology so when does the artist need
the engineer well in at least five
instances no artists and probably no
engineer can be familiar with all the
material processes available and the
number of materials and artists can use
in my own case I listen to the artists
intention and then describe a number of
different ways different processes to
achieve the artists goal this
conversation often occurs very early in
the process of creating a work of art
then there is the near-obsession to be
novel to do something never done before
casting and fabricating are really
fairly straightforward new technologies
appear and are used but for the most
part solutions of this type combine
unusual or offbeat ways of doing things
for exact for example casting aluminium
or bronze around stainless steel
stopping the anodizing process at a
point where the artist can paint colors
rather than dipping using plating
techniques selectively welding metals
together with different color welding
rods these suggestions sounds simple but
they can be a great use to an artist in
achieving a unique
then there's the exchange of information
between artists and engineers the artist
wants to know why something happened
what things can't or won't work and post
and perhaps most importantly which
things might work this sometimes
difficult for an artist to explain what
he's trying to do for it may not be
completely clear to himself the engineer
fabricator must be a good listen
listener able to pay attention and
Intuit what the artist wants providing a
source of imagery italics is visually a
fantastic place artists come to talax to
see all the different work being made
feel the energy of the place and are
enormous ly stimulated and motivated to
create new works and finally make it all
cost-effective in the end everyone has
to deal with the costs let's return to
the fabricator who wants and needs an
image of what is to be made the artists
as creators sometimes does not have a
strong sense of how important it is for
the fabricator to have that final idea
available - it confusion and muttering
result as artists and fabricators slip
past each other
pursuing their common but different
goals fabricating is important to the
artist but in a different way than for
the fabricator fabricating gives the
artist the opportunity to identify
elements he may want to use in his
composition the fabricator works from a
model of drawing a sketch some kind of
guide while the artist has none of these
and only gets exact when he's completed
when the sculpture is finished another
sticking point in the push-pull between
fabricating and creating is that the
fabricator cannot provide the artist
with elements of imagery only the artist
can decide what images he wants he may
recognize and use some images from the
work of the fabricator but only after he
has understood what has been made can it
have a place in his work to summarize
the artist is expressing an emotion of
feeling he is not conscious of until it
is expressed the engineer participates
in the process by making a plan to
accomplish the artists vision
the fabricator follows a plan with a
clear objective and artifact as the goal
I won now to talk about how different
artists work most artists come to the
foundry looking for advice and
consultation on how to achieve a
specific result these artists have
mostly resolved their work in the studio
and have well form ideas of what they
want often they will have discussed with
the foundry particular aspects of the of
a project long before it is completed in
fact the discussions often affect how
the sculptures are fabricated this
technical advice becomes a compositional
element which the artist may use or
discard some typical founder responses
for artists are as follows Rory
Lichtenstein the pop artist wanted his
sculpture to have an industrial finish
like a galvanized trash can to keep the
pop image even while using the very
permanent and expensive process of
casting Nancy graves loves color Nancy
Kim comes to sculpture as a painter and
so we did enameling of the cast bronzes
and she also liked the direct casting
and so we figured out ways to cast
lobster claws and flowers and other
flora and fauna with her signature touch
of fragility and metastability for
Richard preset Dart we've already seen
how we took in that two-dimensional
painting and turned it into a 12 foot by
12 with the door these are some of the
things we've done for various artists
but the artists I'm going to focus on is
the affor with his assistant Earl
Childress chooses to work directly and
at scale at the foundry
this is a bold expensive complicated to
work but what it does it gives Frank the
possibility to assert artistic influence
at every possible stage of fabrication
and therefore clarifies how one artist
can and does work
for Stella a major goal is to include as
much information as possible in his work
to make it as rich and full of character
as possible he wants the complexity of
history and chance and he is not
bothered by the source of the richness
for example human beings always bring
the promise of enriching you work not
only by their actions actions but by
accident as well Frank will ask for
something to be done then that piece of
metal cut that piece into four elements
the logical question is okay what angle
is the bend to be if you want a
symmetrical other cut pieces to be equal
sizes these questions Frank never
answers he says bend it cut it he's
looking for richness Frank is open to
everyone's ideas and suggestions looking
for that idea he could never think of
himself
perhaps the cutting or bending of the
material will be done in some new and
interesting way if it doesn't work if it
isn't interesting he dumps it he will
not compromise working for some artists
is like making a product this group of
artists is trying to achieve a specific
result but Frank Stella is composing
images building the sculpture feeling it
go together when Frank is at work making
images accepting some rejecting others
there's a real sense of fitting the
specific elements to each other making
them feel right as well as look right
historicity of elements is what Stella
wants not in the traditional way but in
a new way the old way was go to the
studio and do trial and error
experiments now there are too many
possibilities too many complexities the
artist needs help to understand the
possibilities so he goes to a fabricator
liked Alex even so Stella is very
unusual in his quest for richness he is
eager to use any possible imagery the
process of fabricating offers this is
not what most artists see Frank thinks
that the process of testing does not
give people ideas people get ideas by
thinking Frank says if the artist has a
novel idea feel that he feels good if he
has an original idea he is
people value expression they don't have
enough of it art gives back something a
notion of the nature of the material of
casting of man using tools for shape and
form materials a sense of all the forces
a lot of them at work to make something
is to act like God to make you must use
force in your mind one of the big
differences for stella between art and
engineering is the value of an original
idea an art in an idea in art is only
good once thereafter it is repetition
but a good engineering solution can be
used many times over and over until a
better solution presents itself
sometimes engineers feel artists are
capricious and self-indulgent when
really what they are responding to is is
this fact that they must avoid
repetition what are some of the ways
Stella works that can be applied to
engineering for starters take his
openness to ideas other than his own and
his own quest for richness Stella
doesn't care where ideas come from he
wants work rich in ideas to some this
might sound like plagiarism but it isn't
there's a difference between using what
exists as a springboard for your work
that is the basis for your work and my
personal experience over the past 10
years I can report that everything we
use at the foundry tools cutting tables
work benches dumpsters drops that's
what's left after forums been cut out of
a metal sheet all have been included in
Frank's imagery of course the ultimate
drop is another artist scrap sculpture
which of course no one can use but it is
tempting for what could be a better foil
a better alternative view than another
artists sculpture next is Frank's effort
to stay uncommitted to keep as many
possibilities open as as possible no
matter how many problems this causes the
fabricator with his need for a vine for
a final vision the goal to be achieved
remember the fabricators skills are his
knowledge of the means necessary to
achieve a given in
they're the artist is substituting
images testing trying to see what works
best
sometimes unsure until it is done well
the fabricator rides
how can one work for someone he thinks
who doesn't seem to know what he's doing
while in fact the artist is doing
exactly what he must do to complete the
project in conclusion I want to do two
things the first is to review what the
artist as typifies by frank stella does
and then to draw some conclusions as to
what might be applicable to the
education of the young engineer first
what I see Frank doing what I will call
the artist way get as much history and
richness as possible into the art
including the processing and the
evidence of man working with tools do
not commit to soon stay as open as
possible as long as possible to other
solutions for it is in the making that
one sees fulfillment of his ideas be
aware of changes in the effect those
changes have a brief tale we were making
a lot of stainless steel castings for
Stella in three or four a project for
another artist came in the required 316
as an engineer I'm accustomed to looking
at these materials finished and finished
it's almost impossible to tell them
apart and the differences in composition
are not great so to give someone 316 is
like being moved into first-class seats
that if the tourist section has been
overbooked
but we made castings in 3/16 s for a
while and then switched back to 304
almost immediately a cry wanna what's
going on it turns out that 316 in the as
cast condition looks very different from
304 something we engineers had been
totally unaware of but not the artist
finally invest so if the artists idea
fails the artist fails if you want to
get more out of something give more of
yourself that's the way of the artist
all of them make sense to me and deserve
serious consideration by young engineers
but there's more bright young people
come to MIT to learn to
the latest and the newest technology
what works and how it works in the study
of Science and Engineering a discarded
or disproved idea is just that discarded
interesting perhaps only in where it was
wrong in engineering there's also a
real-world 12 test questions totally
inappropriate the works of art get asked
of the engineer like what's it for
did it work did the bridge fall down
contrast that to art we're discarded
ideas and artists can and do reappear
and certainly in art there is no sure
test for the quality of art what can
happen then to the young engineering
student which does not happen to the
artist is that he may over value the
contribution of his teachers and either
ignore or not develop awareness of his
feelings and the importance of
expressing those feelings we need to and
I hope are doing so as evidenced by all
of us here today make young agent
engineers aware of the importance of
including their own feelings their own
expression in the solutions to problems
they will face in their careers we can
make that more possible by providing
opportunities and making sure that these
opportunities are important to our
community for our students to express
themselves or failing that provide them
with frequent opportunities for
aesthetic experiences whether or not
this will make better engineers can and
will be debated but art an aesthetic
experience will do what it always has
done enrich the individual and give a
historical and aesthetic perspective an
artistic dimension to our students
understanding and aspirations and given
the ever-growing power of engineering
perhaps it's not too while to suggest
that this new engineering will give
creators like Stella compositional
liberties unimaginable not long not so
long ago perhaps one can even imagine
students being taught as I have learned
working as an engineer for artists
function can follow form
thank you
[Applause]